mais après après voilà un sur facebook
j'ai fait plusieurs postes en effet
trois ou quatre au moins mais bon arrive
petit à petit avec un peu de retard mais
bon 18 heures c'est une mauvaise heure
pour nous j'aurais déjà dit quand ils
l'ont fait que 19 heures c'était mieux
parce que parce que les gens ils
travaillent en france faut le savoir on
va je pense que les postes youtube
serait plus intéressant je suis d'accord
en fait
switch to issue mais le truc c'est que
c'est que je veux pas pour irma chaîne
youtube avec des annonces et à la prod
chez ce midi à d'autres trucs ça se
passe comment de participants dans en
fait il ya que les mecs qui ont en fait
y'a des mecs qui se désinscrivent de
chez nous quoi c'est horrible et ce sera
tous les vendredis
moi je vais commencer vos parties dans
une minute non mais pour pour avoir les
pubs
comment tu t'appelles twitch switch on
joue contre une carabine un argentin leo
msa et que les argentins allons lui fait
quoi à l'ebit m'ont fait cavalier 600 à
lui faire des 5 et vous allez voir on va
s'en va se marrer
bîmes dégage regardez la paix elle est
là qui se prend pour gagner la paix à
l'aise de kara pyun beam assist dégâts
je prends le pion tu ne sais pas jouer
fait attention
allez on se motive à saillon la nuit en
sueur là on a vu car look avec un repas
une en sueur
bon écoute et on va prendre et on va
faire rue six mois jeudi
pour le moment on n'a qu'un pion - mais
on a ouvert des lignes mon avis on n'a
qu'un pion - les mecs et contre ce pion
on a quand même ouvert un maximum de
lignes donc ça c'est quand même très
intéressant et on va bien voir ce que ça
donne
les lignes ont été ouvertes
alors si les pions france et ça va faire
damas cinq échecs forcé kelly c3 est fou
prend ses 5 et après on jouera rock et
on jouera un jour à l'activité quoi on
est pas mal les mecs sérieux on est pas
mal saluons n'est pas malice et puis on
prend fait damas un coquet il protège
j'ai envie de dire on fait fou à six
auxquelles on veut [ __ ] en bessin est
fou prend des cinq dames à 5 et chaque
étape est de fous eux j'ai envie de dire
on fait des pièges attention les mecs
ont fait des pièges alors je suis très
heureux de tante et mon premier péage de
la journée évidemment évidemment bible
piège la double attaque mais oui car à
peine youn
tu ne vois rien
oh là là en 15 + 2 les mecs se prend
d'une petite magouille comme ça c'est
quand même triste c'est sean allez les
mecs je marque bonpoint
allez je ramène mon fond à la team
france a le piège du dimanche haut la
pls la pls de kharouba yuna les
abandonne abandonne abandonne carapa
yuna les allées l'argentine voisine
non mais attendez qu'est ce que c'est
que ça il va me la jouer non mais
attends ça abusé non
ça abusé et tu joues en quinze plus
après s'être coûte à une pièce demain on
est sorti de la théorie n'était plus là
et plus personne vous avez vu les mecs
quand vous sortez de la théorie apprécié
sept coups à tela non je suis là y'a
plus personne les magasins ils sont en
apnée ils sont en apnée théorique
stériles ils savent plus ce qui se passe
des cas ces quatre mais cinq années où
je suis bête et 2000 dégage
ouais mais bon il sous on se sent
meilleur que krikor ouais bah ça ne te
dire c'est pas très dur alors d'amd 6 à
lévis mme hallé bim aller binh phu prend
ses 5
attention à tes petits pièges sur b4 ou
prendre des captures iturbe un faux pas
se faire contre mam oublier hills où
aller non mais krikor qui a bien joué
quand même mis à rire joue d'ailleurs un
mais faudra voir la vidéo de demain
matin où j'explique un petit peu tout
par rapport à krikor pourquoi le match
s'est mal passé pour krikor et c est ce
que je peux faire des quatre qui prend
des 4 un an qu'est ce que je vais faire
des quatre fous prendre des quatre tours
b 1 dames à 6 mais je pourrais pas sûr
reprendre mon écoute on va voir sous
sous hills où ça se passe bien pour
lacombe communauté hispanique voilées
jouent carapa yuna assez loin dans la
game mis bien en pls non le petit piège
la salle annie en pls je crois je crois
que ça l'a mis en pl ace
j'ai envie de dire sueur alors il fait
quoi la carapa youn est ce qu'on va
finir la partie avec plus de temps qu'on
l'a commencée allez venez on fait venez
on fait un challenge on finit avec plus
de temps qu'on a commencé le délire on a
15 et 15 18
on doit tout le temps reste au dessus de
15 minutes on se fait le délire ou pas
les mecs dans le chat vous en pensez
quoi de ce délire est ce que c'est un
délire qualitatif est-ce qu'on est dans
un stream de qualité si on fait ça
allait je fais des cinq au prochain la
cie
si fais rien je fais des 5 mais là c'est
clair ils jouent contre à 22,88 le mec
est dans les dents et dans la game
machin alors voilà je aller autant on
tente vraiment de terminer au dessus des
15 20 questions perd on perd un super
yard sait par ailleurs barrio le
challenge c'est ça c'est pour ajouter un
peu de piment joue tout tempo il doit
être écoeuré je vais les curés de la vie
il va plus jamais rejoint les tournois
vas-y 1 pb 5 des 5es à cinq je te bloque
peut-être magic a eu 4 à la tour ans et
8 avant on est bien s'y faire car je
pense je bouffe tempo et on voit après
faut quel était ton père après 1 mais
bon c'est la vie au moins s'amuse on n'a
qu'une vie urbaine et one life
si on le bloque makine tour ans et 8
il peut faire un truc type qui a aidé
quatre un peu chiant on n'a que trente
secondes pour réfléchir donc fort à
jouer vite peut faire caler des cats
peut être pénible td4 pour une plante un
quart ayant ses 6
mais faire après a4 a5 c'était pas si
simple mais bon
c'est peut-être pas si simple mais mon
cahier des cas tête ont fait pousser 5
et surtout prend à 5 tours prend à 5/4
lycées 600 haletant de bouffer à 3 ok
donc cavalier là on fera pousser 5 et
surtout bouffe tour bouffe qui a valu b3
on a aussi tout reprend à 3 ok donc sur
calais des quatre chemins c'est fou ces
cinq tempo on réfléchit même pas et
sinon je pense quand tous les autres cas
ont fait cavaliers ou 4 tempo savoir
faire qui les prend des deux un peu
bloqué les pions sera organisera plus
tard mettre le fond f6 ok je pense qu'on
sait ce qu'on va jouer et ça lui a rasé
qui ce qui est nouveau ici
carrillo 5 c'est la même idée que
l'autre on va faire food et 6 et surtout
prend à 5 tours prend à cinq cavaliers
c6
il n'y a pas qu'à lycée cas que
pouvaient pas clouer j'hallucine et j'ai
peur de casser cazilhac louage n'ya pas
clouage et sur kelly c6 du coup on a
tout reprend 1,3 il
il sous ok c'est chaud on veut jouer
très vite contraint et qui prend du
temps on prend d'énormes risques on
prend d'erreur me risque mais je pense
qu'on a tous sous contrôle portant
vraiment pas de perdre du temps pas
perdre de temps pas perdre de temps pas
perdre de temps finir au dessus des 15
minutes finir au dessus des 15 minutes à
saluer à s'appliquer fr qu'il nous ment
pikachu dans le chat il est là ça
piquait fr j'ai envie de te dire ça
pique ou sa pike
allez les mecs on continue notre
challenge on va on va lui chercher le
pion à 3 allez y réfléchit et réfléchit
à fond le niveau de sueur et grands qui
essaient 6 tourcoing 3 tempo continue à
jouer vite je vous vite et bien
c'est vrai qu'on est pas mal les mecs on
lui a tapé dessus on a du coup il va pas
pouvoir faire les deux pions pas saigner
voilà que son cavalier qui est un petit
peu chiant mais on va le gérer
s'il fait tout reprend à trois on va
faire fou prend à 3 tours un fou ces
cinq tours à six dames beyssade comme ça
le foot c'est ça qui contrôlent
approuvera du tai-chi cas et décès to b
on fêtera le fonds b 6 on fera le fond
en b 6 qui en 17 on fera à tour ses huit
cahiers b8 un jour je sais pas quand on
va se débrouiller on va chasser de kabal
et après ça ira tout seul je pense qu il
est 17 notre prochain coup avec id
cavalli quelque part et thurau est
vraiment fou ici comme ça surtout
raciste dame 17 on contrôle tout état et
17 qui revient je pense qu'on est tous
entre eux protègent ils sous à va faire
qu'il ya 17 quand même
et on va les chercher fou des six
cavaliers 5 pour aller mettre le cap
vers ces quatre ou cinq on fera un petit
coup de hache 6
on va gérer ça les mecs on a trois
parties kiev c'est ça non on a six
parties au final trois fois 2
ça devrait aller 1
un réel
quand on est capable de la perdre un
élément qui ne prend pas de risques ne
s'amuse pas j'ai envie de dire une
nouvelle expression sélection c'est un
peu ennuyeux comme partie pas
passionnant mais bon là on a tout petit
challenge devrait comprendre l'avancé ce
qu'on peut finir à 16 minutes qui a valu
à eux quatre ces 3 way et peut-être
qu'il ya eu 4 c3 c'était pas mal moi je
vais me débarrasser de son truc moi je
veux me débarrasser de son cavale en
fait mais sérieux il prend des plombes à
jouer c'est hyper loin vers l'est
peut-être fait d'armes pranger 5 kf3
échec on gagne la dame est plus ou moins
obligé d'échangés va mettre le foin f6
c'est quand même très sécurisant se fout
un f6
c'est quand même très sécurisant alors
en profiter vous lui proposez les
chances des dames parce qu'il veut jouer
à chelsea c'est qu'on puisse pas prendre
comme ça on va ramener la dame vers eux
cinq peut-être
puis vers 4 puis le fou en 5 pour bien
bloqué le pion
je pense qu'il va faire b6 ici on va
pouvoir faire dame cas provoquer les
changes prises prise décède fou aux cinq
tours c'est un tour b 8 tours ces huit
échecs il va penser qu'on va devoir
faire un tour france et 8 mai on fera
watch cette île va pas l'avoir vu vous
allez voir non ils continuent pas comme
ça alors mettre le font eux cinq quand
même déjà peut-être dû jouer des cats
étaient mieux à tous rendez vite ça
c'est sûr j'aurais dû jouer des cats
auraient été plus précis
on a bloqué le pion maintenant
on a bloqué le pion
des milliers de couples pour gagner
autour des trois menaces absolument rien
las absolument rien comment on finit sa
facilement
sur 100 je me pose des problèmes pour
rien
je me pose des problèmes pour rien là
j'suis pas pourquoi j'ai pas j'ai pas je
suis pas les prendre son pion je suis
allé mettre dans le caca tout seul
j'aurais dû faire des quatre plus tôt
bon je faire d'un match 4 qui est
mauvais jusqu'à ce qu'un très mauvais
d'ailleurs peut-être pas si mauvais que
ça remarque mais ok je veux faire d'un
match de damas un échange et les dames
et si ce bar avec saddam peu à la f3
éventuellement sur quoi je ferais dame
c4 et je repartirai de ce côté là
f4 ok j'ai refoulé 6
mais oui j'ai pas joué parfaitement
clairement je me pose je me pose tout
seul des problèmes je suis en train de
me poser tout seul des problèmes et
poser des me poser des questions que je
devrais pas me poser ok il fait en f3 va
faire dame 7
mais oui je me pose des questions que
j'aurais jamais dû laisser son pion
avancé aussi loin mais on va récupérer
ça va aller tout seul mais mais j'aurais
dû gagner plus facilement
je m'en veux un petit peu
c'est pas très grave mais c'est pas
normal on va le prendre
ça fera toujours plaisir mais laurent h
700 prépare la tour en g8
on prépare tour g8 ici 5
il va réussir à sauver son pion j'aurais
dû faire rage suite tu aurais été plus
fort peut-être quoique les dames les
deux échecs qui s'est il fait dams et 8
ouais on l'a laissé
on l'a laissé trouver du jeu ne joue pas
mal tout d'un coup un alors faut pas
conduit notre challenge
ge est capable de la perdre ça
la perte peut-être pas mais dame ces
deux dames ma chance et belles
ressources qui l'a trouvé j'ai pas
comment on a fait pour se retrouver à
mal comme ça part mal on reste bien mais
comment on est on est plus temps sous
contrôle que ça saddam arrivants sémites
c'était c'était pas prévu sur dame c'est
cet adam prend 1,6 non mais des quatre
c'est bien ça permet de réactiver le fou
ça c'est plutôt intéressant c'est ça je
comprends rien
que tu prends ici
et un truc qui me fait peur c'est tout
reprend tour ici mais je crois que
préfou pro f katia padam c8 puissant
était tour g8
moi je craque tout d'un premier set du
coup
il a pas d'échec je vais dame des landes
à machin dame échec échec
pas si simple
voilà il fait tout rejet 3 je fais fou
prend il fait tout rejet huit chefs ou
1,5 et je crois qu'il a plus d'échecs et
j'ai idée tout reprend bessette après
c'est fantastique en fait je suis en
difficulté
dams et 2,3 kg faire des trois hockey
trouve des ressources
vous prend ici sur l'échec c'est un
échec nous ici
qui par là bas genre deuxième échec si
paris si je vais lui coller un troisième
échec avec la tour et je reconnais un
échec comme ça que j'en ai souffert pour
gagner ce truc je lui colle un échec ici
je les collais un échec ici et je
connais un math peas ou yes première
victoire pour l'équipe france première
victoire pour l'équipe france à on
rejoue une revanche bimla grob bim bim
bim dit la grab le niveau 2 sur eure
karup ayoun des 5 le nouveau jet de e.on
et la bible à grand plat crop lacrampe
la grotte puis je le gagnais même pas
donné même plus plus de 2000 quand même
des volets faut la gagner à les parties
twitch switch faut les gagner les
parties 1 c'est pas parce qu'il à peine
2000 que ça se gagne tous seuls 1,7 toi
tu crois que ça se gagne tout seul mais
ça se gagne pas tout cela j'aurais dû
faire un truc pour qu'il fasse ses sinon
est ce que toi tu les bat facilement les
joueurs à 2000 c'est pas si simple à un
les gens ont l'impression la camsa c'est
que c'est facile de battre des mecs à
deux mille 2000 c'est pas si mauvais
hein c'est pas si mauvais et 2000 ça
joue déjà un peu aux échecs il ya
peut-être quelques années deux clubs y
soumet ça lag rome il n'a jamais vu ça
râle mais également sur ce serait cool
qu'on soit deux sur de la direccte pour
faire du bien la team france allait la
team france allait la team france on y
va alors prendre une fois en d5 pour
commencer on espère qu'ils aient des
cadres damas catéchèse pour lui refaire
une pause pipi sous on espère les hills
où aller on est pas mal
peut-être un jour ce qui est des cats à
damas cat échec qui a fait qu'ils
arrivent ici sont effectués problème 6
échecs prison lui refait dame g4 la même
que tout à l'heure mais dans l'autre
sens tu es là non je suis là on sent
qu'ils souffrent face à la grogne une
nouvelle fois apprécié coup dans
l'ouverture il est déjà dans le dur on
sent
on sent que les ouvertures c'est dur ce
pas ce qui se passe dans les autres
partis dits l'ouverture du tueur fumée
complètement complètement
on joue sur les alpes on est menés 13 2
les mecs on se fait défoncer des mecs on
est menés 13 de tout le monde se fait
défoncer c'est grave on se prend on se
prend un massacre là 13,2 heureusement
que je suis là pour sauver l'honneur les
mecs sains parce que sinon on est mal de
chez mal aller non arrêtez tous les mecs
haï la c6 attendez attendez est-ce que
je peux prendre aller jusqu'à y coule
pas je calcule pas j'ai pas calculer
mais je la sens bien je me lasse dame
prend des quatre il peut pas bouger le
truc parce que sinon sinon y'a le fou
derrière c'était pas complètement gagné
parce qu'on a plein de trous partout
ouest attia fous ces cinq encore et sur
pions prend le roi il est tellement au
bois c'était peut-être pas terrible ma
variante mais j'ai tellement envie de
lui placer la même taille de la même
tactique que dans la partie 1
mais en réalité peut-être que je suis
très mal je sais pas si le roi survie
vraiment en fait
ça peut être un peu un peu un peu hard
ok kf3 j'avais pas pensé les mecs
et ouais parce que j'ai pas leur qu'ils
ont affaire aux f1 avec l'idée que les
frangins d'engranger quatre et le
cavalier est enfermé attention à pas mal
de trucs emprise que je m'associe dames
quatre échecs maintenant ça peut être un
peu dur mais la cave à lieusaint qui la
cave a lieu cinq qui défend tous il à
cava lieu 5 1 qui a eu lieu cinq cas
d'accord ok il ya cavaliers ou cinq on
fera des 4 et sajoo ok le coup n'est pas
passé loin
n'était pas loin de se la faire coller
quand même il n'était pas loin de se la
faire coller s'est pas passé loin ok va
peut-être faire cavalier 5 des cas qui
est des trois dames b3 qui est français
un dame prend bessette l'hymne à mékhé
detroit il menacera matin de 4 qui est
des quatre qui est des trois il menacera
de la mef de maths
ah ouais ça ce sera super pénible en
fait haoues fait ke 5 en fait j'ai pas
vu quand il rebondit en d3 et menaces
matin f2 bah ouais c'est hyper chiant ça
voici voit ça on est mal peut-être qu'à
radio 5 chefs dan b3 en premier et après
dégâts mais y aura foule f6 avec tempura
voilà on est super mal les mecs là on
fait la gueule
alors on est vraiment très mal on est
vraiment très très mal peut-être sur qui
a valu au 5 août juste faire qui a valu
au dos et se développer en fait
on est vraiment malin
et oui on m'en fera cavalier de évoqué
résiste when you see fait qu'ali detroit
on aurait dames quatre échecs au québec
on serait inclus ou un poil plus vite
il ya 14 à deux on se fait défoncer des
mecs sains c'est insupportable
c'est sérieusement insupportable
six mois pour y réfléchir autant
franchement c'est à dire un peu relou la
carapa youn la lunule pourquoi papillon
f3 ce que je menace rien fait si tu f3
je suis souvent un clouage donc j'ai
plutôt envie tu vois de sortir les
pièces un petit peu de cash game assez
mal placé
du coup j'arrive de ces drames
n'évoquait hiver ou quatre peut-être
pour défendre un peu des trucs je sais
pas ce que je vais faire à lyon fait
qu'il y ait deux tempos ce truc c'est
tout média sont mal placés en fait donc
peut-être kg 3 au moins quand je fais
des quatre qui est des trois jolis
cailloux cas du deffand f2 j'attaque
apsys c'est pas idéal mais au moins je
vivote quoi aprilia fouet 3 qui est
super pénible ici il ya beaucoup de
courant pour un froid tu as fait d'un f4
je crois taz un peu
ce qui est sûr ce qu'on me fait
énormément réfléchir c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle
on se fait défoncer surtout les
échiquiers quoi 15,2 ben spies
salut à toi bon écoutez la voix de la
sagesse serait de faire d'un f4 mais la
voie de la drogue dit damas six c'est
quand même super ridicule damas si son
attaque avec une pièce n'a absolument
rien franchement si on la perd ça
m'étonnerait pas ok maintenant l'idée
c'est de faire des quatre cibles jusqu'à
ignorer dame français si s'échangent des
dames est franchement celle là si on la
perd pas c'est très cool qui a pris la
tête des ventes sympa genre fous ces 5
des cas qui est des trois menaces maths
on va chercher kf4 et pour un f4 dame
prend ses 6 contres échec on encaisse la
tour hockey fouet f3 je pense que c'est
très bien joué de sa part là pour la
peine
alors c'est un peu la cata notre roi va
se retrouver encore plus faible ce que
je fais cavaliers des quatre qui est
pourri et je défends des cases jeu
pourrait la perdre rapidement mais enfin
tu mériterais
je n'avais pas de la tenir celle là mais
bon gros avantage autant plus gros
avantage en temps mais j'arrive encore
beaucoup de temps plus donc ça me paraît
quand même plus que compromis sept
minutes ça me paraît plus qu'assez les
monts faut continuer à jouer vite on va
voir comment on va voir comment il
conclut il peut il peut un peu
trembloter là il sait pas ce qui se
passe il ya 16 2 dont le match à 17,2
non mais attendez mais vous perdez tous
quoi mais c'est pas possible qu'est ce
que c'est que cette équipe sérieux pour
le deuxième match je veux une équipe
beaucoup plus solide à faire f quatre
années ont ajouté mme pour
on est complètement foutu
je pense qu'on va la perdre les mecs
sains c'était osé on a essayé de faire
le damas cas d'échec qui était très
mauvais à première vue un ils étaient
très bons vins première vue était très
mauvais à deuxième but aussi du coup
truc est ce que j faire fou prend ici un
ouais
on peut s'interroger au second match oui
je pense je sais pas si on peut remettre
les liens le deuxième match
il est là et pour s'inscrire on va te le
remettre dans le chat et le lien pour
s'inscrire faut s'inscrire au club
d'abord enfin sérieux qu est-ce qui
réfléchit bien sûr c'est plus la team
france on est en vala c'est ouf en fait
le niveau de jeu
t'inquiète pas jean charest pour la
deuxième tu commencé en direct va en
fait la toile je joue je joue ma partie
comme elle mais qu'elle en fait pas mon
idée c'était de jouer vite mon idée
c'était de jouer vite et d'alain peut
voir vos parties mais je vous contera
mais qui est super important je joue
complètement de la merde tu vois mais je
me dis ok peut-être que le mec qui va
jouer un peu vite et machin on va
pouvoir aller vous voir jouer mais en
fait quoi qu'il en soit il joue très
lentement et donc c'est pas évident mais
bon si tu veux
qu'est ce niveau de sueur est important
c'est pas si mal à survivre un bâton
survivre va-t-on survivre à kara
pailloux on a le tee shirt bleu stream
sur le sur le maillot les mecs on est là
on se bat sam key milliards du prochain
match mais on l'avait déjà ça monde et
la samhsa monde et partout le sardine le
but du rapide 7 prendre son temps va
s'appelle rapidement maman m'a dit tu
joues des rapides je joue vite quoi
allez on est là les mecs il est il en
sus arcaraz perriot une île en sueur
allez les chats allez on est des chats
maintenant ça y est on est une équipe de
chat allez ça c'était déjà prévu roi f2
il va faire d'am-dam ici rouaroua f3 ya
pas de soucis tranquille
tranquille les mecs pas de stress pas de
panique le roi est bien
on panique pas ce serait important de ne
pas paniquer dans ses positions la no
stress
pas de stress il ya un point s
pas de stress les mecs on est des points
est son nez partout il n'y avait qu'une
dame il peut pas maté de façon personne
n'a jamais matté avec une dame seule
c'est par ici
il ya de moins en moins de temps allez
on prend des risques
un fil le fou un aveu faire dame france
et si ça allait mettre des échecs
ça s'annonce sur la laïcité l'issue il
il sut issue salle fait suer ce coup il
prend pas il prend pas la pièce en un
vainqueur va se cacher
issu de folie là
si fait tomber cette mega man peu mal
toi c'est ton un peu mal c'est pas mal
d'attac là quand même
enfin le kent superman c'est horrible
on n'arrive pas à mettre le roi l'abri
là c'est chaud
c'est hyper chaud je crois qu'on va la
perdre
je crois qu'on va la perdre
faire ainsi 4
les verrines dapd
mais jean todt d'am dam leca 3 chez 3 on
protège on est bien et après on fait
touré fin on se bat
après une trentaine d'inscrits les
catalans mais ça abusé en fait jusqu'à
prendre l'espace voilà faut le savoir
on est bien on prendre l'espace grosse
prise d' espace faut prendre qu'à toi
on va écouter
si on prend ce fait mater il y aura dam
des trois rois bouche des tours de on se
fait maths est il qu on est très très
malade on va faire dame à 3
on est là on protège
c'est chaud
c'est chaumont encore en vie on se bat
j'ai pas commentaires pas ça mais
appartient
bref de la vie
allez les mecs on est partout on veut
prendre des cadets sur dame de roy g3
tranquille on est raide de partout c'est
la folie j'sais pas comment on peut
tenir ça mais bon allez on part là bas
vous c'est 5
qui est l'âme des trois têtes un jour on
prend f7 à les voleurs à les voleurs
peut-être un jour on prend f7 allaient
tous les fans
qui peut prendre des deux prises en e3
prises et quand il reprend 2,3 et la
tour des mythes matt intermédiaire allez
faut prier pour que ça marche
si ça marche c'est formidable s'ils
ratent le tour des huit marathons fait
ici hills où deux groupes allaient si
j'avais ça marche je veux un grand hills
ou de groupe a il a vu il l'a vu mais ok
en lutte absentions c'était peut-être
pas une bonne idée de taper le pion
d'ailleurs mais ok peut être
comment on peut faire pour s'organiser
ici c'est dommage qu'il ait vu quoi
avec un complètement foot chiche
quant à faire ça
messi fait tour d'amer fuite on est
foutu il peut gagner avec le clouage
touré fuite on est mort
on est mort de che mort pour prendre les
deux et ça gagne
dams et quatre peut-être encore plus
fort
donc on va perdre la dame h4 échec à
l'aller on espère damage deux peut-être
pas l'espérer trop fort parce que là
c'est luis ou quand même c'est dommage
ces cinq secondes par coup là c'est quoi
cette idée de mettre cinq secondes par
coup c'est sam qui a eu l'idée de mettre
cinq secondes par coup c'est abusé 5
secondes par coup allez je tente un
issoufou vous prend 1,3 il se battait
on est là qu on se bat on se bat comme
des morts de faim
wray la vue il voit tout alors à faire
vous prends toi réfuté cheikh lô il a vu
encore il a vu encore que l'on va
prendre espérer qu'il ait pas de maths
il ya des bons réflexes en tout cas et
on va espérer qu'il y ait pas de maths
allez allez les petits
c'est bien joué ça encore il vient me
prendre à revers aller d'un f4 on tient
là casef cette île dam leca contre échec
contre échec contre échec contre échec
petit willy petit oui petit oui petit
car absurde mais quelle défense mais
quelle défense les amis les amis et on a
tous défendus on a tous défendus on a
tous défendu et on a tenu et on a tenu
et on a gagné et on a gagné quelle
défense
tara you buy in en sueur au la sueur
ouais c'est cool les mecs on a gagné à
l'est alors le deuxième match aura
participé faucon s'inscrivent en masse
mais on n'est pas du tout inscrit allez
on va remettre le lien yatenga qibla
qualif on est là on est deux partout on
est en finale on est en finale on l'a
tellement arnaquer les mecs sérieux
allez je vais des liens pour le deuxième
tournoi
on joue le titre les amis ça devrait
être arnaquer d'internet ça doit être
interdite d'arnaqué comme ça veut dire
bien simona mais non vierge simona c'est
la vie ça elle était sympa quand même je
sais pas comment on a tenu ça les mecs
on était complètement l'add on a quand
même arnaque et ça les mecs et toi je
suis tsar et je pense que s'il avait
joué à tour prend prisé tour prend là
j'ai l'impression qu'on faisait la
gueule nous évite échec et fois la fuite
rideau il n'était pas loin
il n'était pas loin ouais c'était chaud
hein on était là on était là là et c'est
là c'est là en fait c'est fou ces trois
fous ces trois salles à milan sur vous
c'est 3 c'est le coût de la partie ces
trois salles année en panique ou c3 il a
paniqué il a fait ça et là on a fait
tout ré fuite
et tout d'un coup et tout d'un coup tout
se défend samba
c'était pas mal l'évaluation de
vertolaye ils nous donnaient en vendée
du moins neuf et oui les amis - 9 - 9
sait rien les amis d'otages qui s'est
fait voler la première mais jamais on
t'aura voler comme j'ai volé car à
feuilles ou le pauvre sa mamie draw
alors quelques de répétition ouais c'est
cher bon allez on est on est on est
presque pas inscrire leur prochain tour
dans mais on est 8 alors que ils sont
cinquante quoi allez les mecs là on a on
a perdu comme qu'on est on a perdu
contre des perdu là on est nul on a été
nul nul nul nul on été nullissime on est
ténue nissim mais c'était ma on l'a
remarqué mais je sais pas si vous aimez
les stream en délire on arnaque on
arnaque des mecs si je sais pas si ça
vous fait qu'il fait ou pas moi ça a
fait kiffer de le voir abandonner au
niveau sûr j'aurais complètement gagnant
jordan des cinq dames eux quatre ils
abandonnent en mode
ah ouais j'en suis sûr comment il a su
et
ouais c'est le genre de partie contre
super et kanté karup ayoun tu dit
j'arrête les échecs dames cas d'échec
chaos fatality samba bref avec le maître
cette musique quand il ya des partis
comme ça alors attends écart a pas une
qui écrit quoi ah oui là il m'a
complètement là il a complètement
insulter c'est génial mais où est ce
qu'il a écrit sa mère je vois pas ah
ouais c'est ça c'est ça c'est
fantastique il va insultes complètement
il en sueur dans le chat il écrit ainsi
hissé par contre
c'est génial et en sueur bon on est très
heureux et bien évidemment on va leur
jouer on va leur jouer
ouais je paye en sueur mais l'a écrit
hills et c'est ça qui est bien et la
chanteuse a souri pour l'amarrer à issou
complet toi il te vénère il est vener
immo vénère après je comprends ces
primes telles pls j'ai fait ce que j'ai
pu et ouais j'ai pas il dit il c'est de
toute façon c'est important mais il a
fait ce qu'il a pu
eh ben il n'a pas pu grand chose bon
allez faut qu'on s'inscrive là on est
deux ennemis là les mecs on est on est
deux joueurs et demi il à s'amuser
allez les mecs non il m'insulte pas en
fait une écurie allait le prochain c'est
15 + 3 on enchaîne ses 5 + 3 la
prochaine et l'inscription c'est ici
mais pensez que c'est devenu un mage
noir la nama
salut dans le château le mec a fait
arriver seule pointe dès que des numéros
10 dans ma team les tontons aussi ici
allez on s'inscrit les tontons à fond on
les défend dans le deuxième match il y
en a marre et je vois qu'il ya et anne
qui est là est un homme qui est chaud il
y avait une chaise 2016 qui est là il ya
triche est dans ta face à l'émoi je
pense qu'on peut le faire le prochain
sacrifices y au talent fou le pin à tort
je pense qu'on est là allez on continue
à s'inscrire à fond on l'écoutera la
prochaine on se fait des petits bullet
on salue malcom and co sont faciles
quand je chante comme une merde totoro
qui disait je me suis ainsi ces gracieux
spéciaux que toi et bien sûr que non
mais bien sûr que non totoro totaux
totoro 932 allez allez on y va on veut
contrôler qu'ils allaient en faux contre
brahim aléas
bon écoute on lui rende le pion de
quatre matchs devraient faire dame
pranger 5 il est nul il est nul c'est
dur de jeu compte des nuls en fait ce
que tu peux pas anticiper leurs coûts
mais qu'ils sont nuls cavaliers ont valu
prendre ça te font j'ai ici s'il va
faire des quatre affaires ou cinq
peut-être pas si terrible que ça ces six
reprises prises on va rockets il raconte
fait rage 5 à prendre de l'espace kessé
4g parce que ça vaut on va prendre là on
va coller une tour en d2 a collé une
couronne 10,8
on va faire 1 h 4 prophylactique il va
prendre prendre on apprend match de
prendre b2 on va prendre des deux des
cinq bien jouer roi et fuite pour faire
effet si ce que vous allez voir un peu
si on peut attaquer le roi
on va se mettre comme ça va faire à
saint-raphaël 6
on va échanger puis on va faire un nul 1
ce n'est pas de chance ok c'est pour se
chauffer c'est pas mal le prendre la
petite nul à la fin parce que je connais
jean françois gentil ouest du club de
monaco et bien sûr où jean-philippe
peut-être plus tu aurais bien sûr je
connais alors pour le prochain tournoi
c'est ici un faut être inscrit au club
france en premier non mais je veux pas
signer
allez c'est comment il s'appelle
starworld 22-23 le monde des étoiles 23
à voilà je suis complètement fons des
tintin des petites finales ouais j'aime
bien quand on fait ses 4 j'aime quand on
fait ses 4 j'aime ça quand on fait ses 4
on va te faire b 4 à 4 et on va tout
jouer à droite on tond on va t'en fermer
ici et on va aller te voir les droits ça
ce pâté ripoux f4
ce sens en fout complètement position
est ferme et pas dit que les cavaliers
soit moins fort voilà on est mal mais on
a plus de temps
on est mal on a plus de temps on est
vraiment mal là quand même
on a plus de casse pour la dame bim bam
et ça marche pas il ya dam des six as et
la poisse ça aurait pu fonctionner en
plus ça aurait même dû fonctionner un
truc pareil gardes le fouillent
absolument
is who is who is who is who is who is
who is who la chante là on a le temps de
te faire ce qu'on veut
issou les deux pions plus fort que tout
il est écoeuré il est écoeuré il s'est
fait arnaquer comme les autres on va
faire une chanson quoi la chanson des
mecs qui se font arnaquer il s'est fait
arnaquer comme une merde allez les mecs
ma mère dit rater ça là on est mal ça là
on va la perdre les mecs
s'ils voient fu hu je dis ouah ça c'est
bien joué
bon
là on est bien foutu nom n'a aucune
chance ou presque
on a quand même les deux pions passer à
l'est les tontons les plombs passé
allez faut qu'il soit quand même ce
sacrément nul pour la perdre mais il
nous a prouvé par le passé qu'il était
nul
hay adams issaiya dame prend m6 eyes
j'étais pas si loin que ça de l'arnaqué
il nous avait prouvé qu'il était nul
mais on n'a pas réussi à la gagner
pourtant il nous a prouvé par le passé
qu'il était sacrément nul ça c'est pas
la théorie qui a aidé de ses mauvais bon
alors
il nous avait prouvé par le passé qu'il
était sacrément nul va-t-il nous
retrouver va-t-il nous leur prouver en
taxant pions
et par là bas et kg 3
bref cette qui passe peut-être
tiens faire à quatre échecs l'acquis des
rois prend toujours un oeil aux
racailles et c5 qui rôdera na na nana na
na waie bon du tout que ça c'est pas si
mal en fait pour lui mais il se fait un
peu rasé mais il se fait un peu raser ou
pas non non il se fait pas rasé il ya
une contre arnaque de folie mais il a
plus de temps son problème c'est la
pendule tu as plus de temps et je te
trolls et je te troll en te donnant la
tour en 1 et tu dégages
tu es en sueur alors comment est ce que
je me la joue et je lui ai changé son
fou ça va lui faire les pieds à l'est
fermé le jeu on va aller se placer bîmes
bim bim bim dupuis ont bien sûr bim bim
on va prendre ça elle reste fair-play on
va se faire plus de folies siffait d'amd
de on a toujours un roi prend damas six
dames à deux dames 1 ok il veut partir
essaye de partir tonton essaye de partir
tu pars quand même même pas je te prends
la tour même pas je te prends la tour
c'était un mystique du conte lui a pas
pris il abandonne même pas honte a pris
ta tour parce que c'est un mystique même
pas en claquant même pas honte l'apprend
bim des gens sur la il est déjà en sueur
il se dit le coût va me pousser les
pions sur la gueule ça c'est
complètement con à ce que je voudrais
c'est génial c'est fantastique c'est
complètement con allez y en a de partout
ok c'est super mal joué c'était super
mal joué ça nous fait marrer du coup bim
et robin
c'est génial c'est une partie tellement
ridicule qui en revient
ah ok
c'est chiant ça j'aurais dû échanger ma
tour j'ai fait j'ai fait de la merde
j'ai voulu m'amuser j'ai mal joué allez
on monte monte à la volée à les bim
on a plus de temps
ah non il nous a fait tomber
allez on en aurait fait on en refait
allez on va le troll est à fond allons
le troll à fond allez grand roque on y
va ça va être un peu juste
on va faire de notre mieux
on menace m'attendre sur b4 on est mal
on est mal de partout
on va devoir revenir pour andrew ce
chemin on prend une fois on était en d4
mon est super mal
c'est la catastrophe à dallas les amis a
voulu trop les ont réussis plus altro
l'élu c'est fini petite finale
désavantageuse
allez on se défend
allez on se défend les mecs
yes yes they nul tu es nul tu es nul
allez on reprend a été nul mais chaque
aller les nuls allez on se bat les mecs
on envoie les coups on envoie les ponts
se bat là on a un petit coup de mou
allez on est parti voilà on est bien on
est bien on est bien on transgresse tous
les principes d échec c'est génial on
envoie des pions sur les côtés fait que
de la merde
bintou rage car âtre c'est fantastique
allez on arrive de ce côté là il en
sueur on protège pas on est super mal
je prends delà à ok ok c'est de donc à
éviter son piège
aucun montres leroy fond
ok
quant à taper le pion
ah [ __ ]
alors on est tombé aïe aïe aïe on manque
un peu de temps on a manqué un peu de
temps c'est dommage c'est très dommage
puisque je fais là je fais n'importe
quoi je fais n'importe quoi
bon allez on s'amuse et on va laisser
attaquer allait prendre les commandes
comment on va faire d'amis ici mais ça
ça va ah ouais ça va peut-être vite fait
en fait allez on va s'activer ça très
vite fait en fait
ok c'est peut-être un peu la merde alors
à choper une calloc'h mais c'est pas si
simple à jouer que ça quand même
c'est hyper dur à jouer pour les noirs
en bullet c'est hyper dur ça
ce camp avec une pièce pour ce truc est
allé pion qui pousse je trouve qu'il
joue très mal par contre
on va faire un échec la catastrophe fada
non non non ah non on est tombé aïe aïe
aïe elle a refusé de jouer alors ce
match bon on a essayé de l'autre les
allées on peut s'inscrire là j'arrive
dans une seconde on a quand même gagné
on l'a quand même battu on l'a quand
même battu on l'a quand même mis en pl
ace peu importe quoi qu'il se passe
toujours en place à l epr et nous en
fait il m'a eu il a fait des primes plus
bizarre que les miens
j'aurais pu le battre est bon c'est pas
grave écouter on remontera plus tard en
bullet j'ai dormi que trois 87000 et mec
je suis je suis un poil claqué sais pas
comment ça se passe et la reina après
mais on se bat fond on se bat à fond les
mecs on est là on est on est bien on est
assis on se fait plaise
on est tranquille j'ai envie de dire
j'ai envie de dire des spas sitôt un
genre vida or death pas si tôt ça a
commencé en quatre minutes on va les
trolls et non mais là je vais quand même
battu j'ai quand même battu quatre et
demi trois et demi donc voilà fin
janvier les nunuches nuls moi mais
j'aurais pu lui mettre plus allez on
commence donc quatre minutes on
s'inscrit à fond pour le tournant n'est
pas très nombreux à l'est on leur colle
on leur colle des bulles on leur colle
des bulles on joue contre chauny thèse
d'une grotte contre 1 24 65 mètres sur
les mecs on va faire une grande is who
is who is who is who is who is who
allait aller et on fait une grotte allez
allez allez je veux je veux voir des
pouces en l'air pour la grob alela grob
la grotte lacropte lacropte lacropte la
grotte à crop
alors que le joueur français s'apprête à
jouer une grotte face à l'espagnol il
est bien le français il est bien le
joueur français qui va sortir la grab
attention et hans à yahoo 3 qui va le
complice fils s
arthur lucas aux deux vignes chasse aux
trois triche est dans ta face aux cinq
sacrifice yacht à l'eau si ce n'est un
giallo sets 6/2 08
emmanuel lignards il est la manu manioc
9 pour le pin à tort aux 10 elias oms
thirion 46 eau douce kahn assis
cauterets esben 64 cents
code postal représente le 64 tonton ben
aux 14 dj did jose au 15e grados s
hikari teacher aux 17 double poney
18/10/10 1984 tombe là c'est ta date de
naissance au 19 thibault 5 855 potvin
vendôme ces listes sabres doré au 22
robert saut lui rends toi le viking s'il
fox 25 ben spies 26 à klaas-jan aux
vingt-sept ont de valo aux 28 et aux
taureaux 93 du neuf trois à six il
représente le 9-3 à tonton même caris &
booba en sueur de vente hors 93
allez allez les tontons on se lâche
allons les défoncer espagnol as les
lettons ton se fait plus les allées moi
je balance une grotte moi je fais une
robe comme ça ça c'est dit ça c'est dit
moi je fais une grotte vous je sais pas
moi je fais une robe
allez on les bat les espagnols on les
bat kim france team france team france
ici c'est paris tonton yak [ __ ] cristal
crypte talent crypte à l'aller cristal
cris talent tu le défonce crypte halo 3
contre louise filet script talent
cristal a les boules crypte al tahrir
qui fait une grotte ping ruiz
allez moi aussi je fais moi je fais ruiz
noir croc blanc à l'écrit talent à
l'écrit talent on se bat
allez on leur fait des graves on leur
fait des ruines ils ont peuvent plus
crypte aller dans la place et vendredi
prochain je sais pas contre qui on joue
mais on rejoue vendredi prochain à 18h
on sera de nouveau là et ça c est ça
c'est vérifiable les amis allez on va
vous péter les tympans les cryptages tu
vas jeu contre césar ou cartes et césar
ou gars et rentre chez toi aller les
tontons devant on est plus forts on est
costaud devant on est costaud est allé
moi je vais faire une grave et c'est la
vérité les amis et c'est la vérité est
là grabels va partir avec les blancs
elle va partir ensemble + 3 la grob il
mesura merci à le renard fou qui vient
de s'abonner au niveau 1
elle renard noël renardeau locaux
laissent pas l'espagnol est à l'espagnol
est la reynard d'eau locaux c'est pour
nos amis espagnols pour pas qu'ils
pensent aller boum boum la grotte
chenilles thèse ou la sueur la sueur
pour finisterre à les boums dessin tu
fais comme lot de tout à leurs bons fous
j'ai de budget 5 la taxe pareil
son cavalier peut plus venir au centre
je contrôle le centre bîmes des quatre
jeunes étaient en sueur devant la grotte
bill dann branche de centralisme adam
west unis thèse en sueur
je me taise
c'est peut-être un chat on fait des
chèques ale à comment fait-on maman ah
bon un petit temps d'arrêt la gent
ritter bim 4 j'ai envie de re dit me cat
& cie fessé 5 on retourne en d1 allez
les amis cavaliers à 6 il veut faire
pousser 5 à la rigueur vous savez quoi
on va le provoquer fous ces cinq d'un
projet 7 mai sur ses seins qu'on va
reculer en d1 on mettra le carélien en
d5 je lis thèse en sueur car il y des
quatre ça honnêtement j'avais pas vu
faut être honnête j'avais pas vu ferdane
d2 c'est dans l'esprit à fond bloque
notre propre fou si ses pions prends je
pense qu'on échange les dames et fo pour
eux quatre on est très bien façon à se
purger cinq est très fort et sinon faire
à troyes b 4 ou b2 grand roque ok mon
cavalier eux deux c'est pas grave faire
cavaler f3 cavale et f4 détroit bon bah
ça devient un peu grave on va faire plus
on prend trois f1 le roi de la grotte
très bien place en f1 il ya aucun
problème les mecs position très saine
pour les blancs
j'ai un peu peur de pousser 5 mais bon
je tire un peu la gueule si fait pousser
5 mais bon vous ces cinq dames c3 qui
est pro f 2 d'un peu d'impro c'est ça
qu'on est là foulée 4
non en fait c'est trois de façon
c'est fou ces cinq là je fais un peu la
gueule quand même
qui développe son cavalier alors comment
va se développer les mecs
peut-être qu'on fait
bams et de vous sortir notre fou on un
camaïeu de on a on a pas mal de coups
candidat mais on est quand même très mal
à quelqu'un tu as rafale dame ces deux
jeux vous cache pas c'est dur on échange
je vous cache pas assez dur mais bon
qu'est lieu de on est là on se développe
trajet oublier ça j'ai pas vu ballon peu
abandonné quasiment aïe aïe aïe on peut
quasiment abandonné mais j'ai pas vu
j'ai pas vu les mecs désolé
j'ai pas vu je suis perdre contre un
maître fide [ __ ] on est carrément
complètement fou tu n'as rien à jouer
y'a rien à faire les amis y a rien à
faire
15 + 3 c'est vraiment pas une bonne
cadence pour la grotte prendre du tien
alliés
la tour qui va quand même venir en d2
ont fait la gueule quand même trois on a
perdu on était sur notre lancée
mais la grave n'est pas passé
on n'a juste aucun jeu si on avait le
roi ans j'ai enfin en h1 la tour quelque
part et tout peut-être mais peut-être
sur qui et b4 on a dû jouer plus normal
on en sueur
puisqu'on perd contre un maître fide
donc ça c'est toujours l'humiliation
maximum 1 c'est vraiment l'humiliation
maximum de perdre contre un maître fide
mais bon
ce qui est génial c'est qui réfléchit à
fond qu à jersey il est tellement nulle
quoi
c'est ça qui est d'autant plus rageant
cry mans sur dame prend ya matt trace
est mise en pls cette mise en pls
cosmique
mise en pls cosmique de la part du
joueur adverse
là il se fait cavalière 4chan sûr on n'a
pas fait ça gagner en un c'est kafka
depuis toujours en sueur km2 purement
dans la finale mais bon le truc c'est
qu'elle est complètement foutue cette
finale sur flu 2 c'est la catastrophe à
bas les amis enfin on aura bien résisté
quand même un sens pêche mais moins trop
de retard
on part avec trop de retard d'affaires
prend 1,2 on va faire de 5 par avec
beaucoup trop de retard
et peut-être la rue il va mieux passé
part de loin mais il envoie les deux
pions avec la troïka
on a tenté une micro activation n'y a
pas de piège à trop de retard
et à vrai dire même ton point f2 gagne
très facilement alors je pense que
j'aurais peut-être fait ton rêve de
personnes
mais c'est fait
et sa paire
parti trop loin
on partait trop loin
c'est dommage parce qu'on le sentait pas
sûr de lui on va tenter la rue 10
j'ai eu l'idée de mettre des rajouts de
temps aussi
quelle horreur
il aurait qu'un pion de ce côté là il ya
encore moyen d'armes à quai mais il
réfléchit tellement longtemps
c'est sûr très frustrant quand tu perds
contre quelqu'un et tu vois que le mec
est nul c'est sûr très très frustrant
ce qu'on le sent clairement galéré 1
je pensais pas qu'il est par là c'est
écoeurant
on va lui faire une ruine on va espérer
que ça marche j'espère que ça reprenne
propre arbitres et à la prochaine
allez ça repart direct on se fait
défoncer 26 à 4 de toute façon on va
tenter une ruse au pire on perd 2-0 à
temps il n'empêche la ruse n'est pas
moyen au pire on perd 2-0 et ça nous
arrangera pour pour la vraie arena qui
débute après mais bon peu de sommeil
j'ai peur que ce soit dur
méthane qui a perdu heureusement devine
chasse à gagner oui s'il est recruté à
l'écrit talent faut le faire
kefu l'esat
allez refaire des six allez on fait une
petite ruiz
et avant des gens qui regardent sans
vision d'histoire du mongy pêchait mais
bien sûr jp chaîne états unis a perdu
méthane façon ce fait on se fait
défoncer un il ya 30 à cinq mois j'ai
perdu aussi on est on est nuls 1 on se
fait défoncer en fait en vrai on se fait
défoncer et moi le premier un précieux
je tente la ruine quoi mais on sent
quand même que c'est pas une communauté
de marans les espagnols
on va voir
on est mal parce qu'en fait il faut
surtout pas faire la grotte quand il a
la rude quand ils peuvent mettre trois
pions en face là on est sur une reese
pas très qualitative parce qu'il a pu
jouer avec 4 donc ça c'est la cata pour
nous mais on va essayer de faire quelque
chose c'est de faire tes b6 dame des
sept grands rock
ce qu'on est en train de jouer un jour
très rapidement de façon et on va faire
grand roque et on va envoyer
sarr écriture l'habitude de perdre
contre barcelone ouais mais la défaite
hier françois jacq honnêtement n'était
pas déçu franchement n'était pas déçu la
défaite d'hier on n'était pas déçu on
était déçu du premier match et il m'a
dit hier on n'aurait rien pu faire de
toute façon donc aucune déception
franchement après on est mal parce qu'on
peut pas à demain on aura beau lundi
pour le match de lundi on aura du mal
françois
mais le beau temps le match de la
norvège vous a vraiment mis en pl ace
autant le match d'hier à ok autant le
match d'hier ça nous a pas ça nous a pas
affectés plus que ça mais c'est sûrement
s'il continue à jouer aussi bien c'est
sûrement la meilleure équipe de la ligue
donc donc on verra après peut-être
qu'ils passeront un peu de régime
on verra si baisse de régime par la
suite mais s'il joue aussi bien que ça
toutes les marques tous les matches ils
sont partis pour un son parti pour
l'emporter
suivant sa disparition ceci pour se fout
de notre gueule peut-être donc donc donc
tu mets ça fait un nom et 1000 euros je
ne sais pas en fait ce que les donc du
coup comme c'est pas à moi qui les gère
je sais pas si c'est vrai pas vrai ou
quoi mais si c'est vrai merci un merci à
toi mais non là c'est de chasse comme
donc je sais pas j'ai pas la main dessus
je peux pas vérifier
malheureusement mais si c'est le cas un
grand merci à toi sinon il faudrait que
j'aille afin que je récupère le stream
lab c'est faux bond pas de chance mais
vu que c'est pas moi qui les gère je
sais pas si on peut défendre ça
ok
ok si c'est du fait que c'est du feq ce
que cela avait été le cas tu ferais bien
un grand merci
comme c'est un fait avec nouveau on
essaye de choper le pion à 6 on essaie
de choper le pion h6 on se bat à fond
ah ah
or là ils n'avaient rien vu mais il a un
poil de chance parce que cinq épaves
marche pas 5 s'oppose à psion prend qui
on prend et qui prend 2,5
malheureusement mais c'est sûr il ya ça
emprise aussi donc on va faire crisser 4
pour commencer comme ça on va se
débarrasser du fou le fou là bas nous
gêner sur cette diagonale dès qu'on
voulait pousser au centre est maintenant
à peut-être faire un truc damev cette
menace a eu 5 quand même là peut-être
cinq crise prises prise est d'alger 4 à
la fin eifeu 5 lui-même du coup ça pour
la peine c'est bien joué
ok je vais prendre une fois je vais
faire damev non je faire de 9,7 quand
même
prendre ici ouais mais y aura par
ailleurs à et chaque camp à 8 à la fin
j'avais pas vu je voulais faire prise
prise est prise et gagner sur le cloud à
jamais à damas huit matches
on est très mal alors
alors on est raide alors on est foutu si
c'est comme ça on est foutu les mecs
on va se prendre le cavalier sur cinq on
peut pas prendre là bas parce qu'à la
diagonale qui est ouvert le roi est trop
faible on est raide on est fichu la
russie n'est pas passé
la ruine n'est pas passé
les mâles on est très très mal
qu'est ce que je tombe vous prend f4 qui
est pro life cette tour prend h 2 mais
il y aura dame français 4 est vrai c'est
horrible et si je fais dame prend 1,6
bon allez faut lutter avec dame point m6
rincez que dame français 4 et hyper fort
ici parce que surtout prend f4 est
peut-être quoique at-on f3 f4 marche
toujours pas bref cas qui éprouvent 6
pour prendre m&a ça en prise à la fin ce
qui a des cas difficiles inquiets
concept
je crois qu'il ya rien qui marche là
j'ai trop de trucs qui reste en prise
tg call c'est bien je vais trop de trucs
qui reste en prise
france 4 et j'ai trop de choses emprise
c'est vrai que cette tour en prison il
prend ici
alors c'est peut-être pas si clair ça
c'était pas si clair parce que là parce
que là c'est pas si clair
pas de chance fou aux cinq qui marchait
bien ça sera était nickel mais j'ai pas
soit joue pour eux 5
mais j'aime faire venir j'ai fait à psa
il va faire ça je vais prendre et je m
le fou en d5 il quand il fait cavalier
là et quand il fait cavalier l'âge
ignorerait je ferai c'est cissé je vais
blindés je reprends comme ça et je me
blinde
peut-être je la tiens dommage qu'ils
rajoutent temps parce que sinon je le
faisais tomber il sait
key s'est pas encore complètement faire
ce n'est pas du laisser faire
j'ai envie j'ai envie d'aller c'est à la
gagner mais bon c'est un peu un peu un
peu tendu
son univers a5 et a6 qui est machin
allées du tap et le truc
j'ai envie de la gagner 1 forcément je
suis ambitieux je l'arnaqué déjà un peu
a été aidé cet échec ici non il fait pas
et je vais faire un truc bizarre je vais
prendre comme ça je vais rester solide
ok
un piège peut déjà faire nul mais je
veux bien évidemment pas
comment est-ce qu'on peut pousser
différents à quatre matchs ça pousse
rien j'ai peut-être dû prendre de l'eau
de pions du coup
chacun ici quand même
donc ils n'ont pas faire un nul qui aura
tenté ça
qui vont lui veut nul
va bouger les pièces pour le moment
comme dirait vlad non non non non je
suis nul je suis nul ah je suis idiot
pas je suis idiot
quel con je suis idiot voit la fatigue
ça des fautes d'inattention avec la
fatigue
aïe aïe aïe aïe je suis vraiment
tellement idiot brasse pas grave c'est
pas grave c'est faute d'inattention avec
la fatigue ça la fatigue ça fait pas mal
joué ça fait faire des petites fautes
comme ça idiote
aïe aïe aïe bon après objectivement
fallait juste faire un nul 1
objectivement fallait juste faire nul
mais bon on essaye de s'amuser 1
on essaye de s'amuser de rigoler parce
que sinon c'est pas drôle sinon c'est
pas drôle ça il y avait vraiment rien a
forcé mais j'aurais dû prendre de
l'autre pions pour essayer de la gagner
ouais le mec a une position heureusement
gagnant de ce jeu pour faire un nul on
l'avait bien a remarqué quand même
j'aurais dû prendre de l'eau de pions
pour essayer de la gagner
c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça c'est la vie c'est pas
grave ça aucune importance ça sent le
match est perdu c'est pas du tout
important
alors du coup
j'ai pris des buts comme toi ouais mais
tu sais pas mais je suis content de la
rue est quand même je vais bien je vais
bien retourner le mac est quand même 24
91 55 + 2 position réellement raid
moi je suis assez content de la gagne
quand même je suis assez loin laghem
après mon essai de la force et puisqu'on
veut rigoler sur le stream 1 mais c'est
pour se marrer alors le dernier tracé du
2 + 1 espérons qu'on va faire quelque
chose ils ont une meilleure team que
nous on va voir on va voir voir ce qu'on
va voir comment ça va finir
la priora l'aréna du vendredi à 21h ça
va être chaud là ce soir je sais pas
comment je vais réussir à la jouer
correctement mais
bon
moment non
on l'a gardé
quand même
à voir donc on est bon je l'aï juste le
lien à 21h ses arénas king
donc
on va partir pour le prochain match
ce qui se passe ce sens il ya le rugby
aussi à 20h45 à ne pas oublier les
tontons 1 montpellier montpellier guy
laso attention enfin glasgow montpellier
plus tôt moi je vois bien une victoire
montpelliéraine jeu parce que vous en
pensez ces 3 + 0 ce soir et tania plus
des 3 puis 0 cette saison
donc
ce n'est pas moi je suis pas inscrit en
plus faut que je me barre du temps à me
fasse quoi le bullet des bureaux dans
une minute waouh les mecs ça ne commence
dans une minute faut qu on les rase en
bullet le but let's à des murs de débats
dans le but une minute j'ai mis le lien
mais ça commence tout de suite les
arénas king sur sur le stream ça débute
dans une minute les mecs faut qu'on
envoie là faut qu'on envoie à fond allez
faut qu'on les batte sur celle là les
mecs qui en a marre les mecs qui en a
marre allez on en voit on envoie du
sérieux mais c'est du 2 + 1 à quelle
cadence de merde
oh là là bas je déteste cette cadence je
trouve que c'est la pire cadence je
trouve que c'est la pire cadence de +1
ceni du bullet ni du c'est pas mal à ce
qu'il touchait pas paraître intéressant
et on va apprendre de ce cavalier en
désormais le fou ici on va faire pousser
4 ce qui a vu sa enfin fuhe 2 et puis on
préparera f4 oui c'est de jouer vite en
d2 c'est pas très grave ça y apporte
partir en f3 en fait c'est génial il
fait le tour de l'échiquier revenir en
f3 justement j'allais faire [ __ ] si
c'est pour vous dire ma petite forme
bon alors fait retour à vous pas très
bien le jeu pas d'imagination
je manque d'imagination et son cas est
peut-être un poil malpas place c est
donc on peut essayer de faire cavalier
simple c'est fini reprises ce prix ce
qui est ces trois dames e3f 4 ok il
prend ça je suis surpris si on va faire
pire et lieusaint qu'on va faire ça on
va échanger sky quand même mal placé et
en plus y'a sa reprise
parce que si jean casas qu'as-tu
peut-être très bien en fait même
sûrement ok je peux pas encaissé à 4
parce que il y avait cinq mais je fais
tourner un jour elle m'a tour au centre
j'attaque un peu ici et sur dame sèche
peut-être d'amd catch attack ici ici
résultat tu tapes est un pion et son
cavalier affiné je souligne très mal
placé c'est le problème de sa position
c'est qu'il est une pièce qui rentrent
pas en jeu et là maintenant menace
peut-être un peu eu 5 mai sur cinq y
aurait c5 encore 5 c5 qui on prend bien
d'apprendre à intermédiaire échec
donc on a on à skype roccat et sur ces
cinq dames ces quatre des cinq d'un
prend b5 pour des huit dames c4 que je
pense qu'on peut prendre je suis pas sûr
mais j'en vois toujours 7000 même
philosophie on ne calcule pas on joue
après envoi ok on revient ancêtres avec
le cac va donc ça c'est parfait 7 5 et
sur ces cinq dames des trois échecs ses
cadres d'un pro b 5 qui ont eu cinq
dames français quatre amis à qui on
prend maintenant à mais que je suis bête
mais que je suis bête mais que je suis
bête pas mais c'est dingue c'est dingue
tout ça ces petites erreurs de fatigue
quoi bon bah du coup c'est un peu
pédagogique dans le sens où si vous avez
mal dormi vous ferez ce genre de gaffe
en fait c'est des gaffes d'inattention
de avec le sommeil ne mâche a cédé gaffe
avec le sommeil ça à la fois en tout cas
pour moi ça marche comme ça je suis
tellement dégoûté
j'avais tellement dominé stratégiquement
ça m'énerve de perdre comme ça
sérieux c'est écoeurant genre et le pion
à
c'est un truc stratégique typique de
bloquer ces 5 et d'envoyer de piora
savall qu'elle peut revenir paris s'est
offert un poil gaffe je suis capable de
linda manara maintenant je le sens
pierre pousse bien on en voit yes
tu es tombé des nues yes bon c'est
mérité parce que c'est mérité
c'est mérité parce que c'était mérité on
sait pas pourquoi on la méritait qu'on
l'a mérité
bams abusé comme j'aime à jouer ça abusé
le e5 telle domination en fait
stratégique de a à z tellement mal joué
c'est tellement nul ça aurait été une
pure ans de perdre
suite et est écoeurant de perdre
alors enfin x 6
pas mal choisi son masque et deux échecs
en fait il faut prouver phare aussi du
coup à faire cavalier mais si on fait
foot.fr ffu prend ici
oui bon à gré du matériel n'est ce pas
ok il fait ça n'ont affaire d'armes b5
va forcer les changes des dames
il va pouvoir jouer la finale
je fais un fils pour éviter car a lieu
cinq et on va faire aveu si ça arrive ça
être fou des 6 es tranquille c'est bien
lui colle un petit deux heures laon
bullet en espérant que les mecs assure à
côté
allez
non c'est 5 c'est toujours bien des
changes et puis on voulait on va pouvoir
faire grand roque tranquillou
sans lui colle un petit échec au passage
on est le fou ici le pion à 6 tranquille
en fait retour des cinq tours des 8 et
on va y aller
5 quand même au moins on contrôle un peu
j'aimerais peut-être tout ce qui est
quand même la tour en d6 c'est un coup
perdu c'est pas grave à la rigueur on
joue vite on va mettre la tour ici on
recule le fou ça c'est pas un problème
faut que je mette le pion aux cinq
rapidement là j'aurais dû jouer 5 ça
c'est bien mon bloc un peu ça et on va
faire tour des huit on va prendre de
l'espace maintenant au centre faut faire
parler des tours maintenant on va faire
un échec que les fous en d4 on peut
échanger du matériel mois
ok tour des cinq ici pour aller faire un
tour prend 1,5
ok c'est quatre tours des cats on va
ignorer hockey surtout reprend ces cas
tu veux faire c'est 3 tu vas te faire
j'ai 6 f ok on va t'on va rentrer dans
son piège je veux faire c'est 3 pour
enfermer n'ont même pas auquel on va
prendre une fois en faire un premier
échec
deuxième échec un troisième échec
quatrième échec est un échec et mat il
sous 2,0 voilà on est revenu nous a
battus 2 0 3 en 5 + 2 on aurait pu faire
un ennemi de et demie mêlant bullet on a
fait respecter la loi
on a fait respecter la loi les amis mais
bon mon père quand même 19 à 8 mais bon
on a on a en inde et nos points à
l'équipe
on a marqué deux points on a marqué nos
points on a marqué deux points
tu as bien
hop on a marqué nos points enfin
démarquer fallait marquer mais bon on va
perdre quand même
bon
c'est dommage qu'on est pareils mais
c'est derrière on est moins fort on a
des petits lots on se fait dominer
derrière devant on est plus forts devant
on est plus fort mais derrière on a
souffert c'est dommage c'est dommage les
amis c'est dommage des amis
on a perdu condé perdu les mecs donc on
sera de retour vendredi prochain pour le
prochain match à 19 heures il faudra
qu'on gagne quoi je sais pas contre qui
on joue
je vais aller je vais vous dire contre
qui on joue et en a marre pas mais c'est
relou d'avoir perdu n'a perdu contre les
espagnols et vendredi prochain on joue
contre les portugais [ __ ] ah non mais
si vous perdez contre les portugais la
semaine prochaine les mecs qui en a
marre 1 si vous perdez contre les
portugais y en a marre on n'a pas le
droit de perdre contre les portugais
franchement faut faut gagner la semaine
prochaine non mais là devant plus on
était bien coincé derrière on est on est
témoin double poney quand même qu'elle
va être gagné une partie contre cénac
angelo bravo double poney double poney
en perd 12 de 22 12 ans mais sérieux sur
les bullet on était pas mal an devant on
a été solides on va les voir ce que fait
crypte à la cristal qui a perdu la
deuxième but un script halle all à la
crypte talent [ __ ] c'était notre mec
quoi comment tu perds [ __ ] et ritag
c'était marcher dessus
pannes ont échangé les dames c'est vrai
elle était passée au nom quelle horreur
quelle horreur crypte talent à c'est la
cata 23 12
allez on va voir arthur aller arthur
lucas arthur lucas mais non il a perdu
on a perdu on perd on perd toutes les
parties arthur lucas en sueur oh là là
c'est la catastrophe à la halle et elias
elias elias arrêtant de la plus loin
plus l'écran qui est bien cadré mais on
sent quand même on a quand même
l'énergie qui avec nous on recadre
allez il ya ce elias elias elias années
ne donne pas ne donne pas d'autre ne
joue vite et bien je vous fais tu es
bien elias ouais c'est bien ça y est
aussi allé dias et je visitais bien
aller il la tient hélas non non non non
hilton non il donne le pion non il
n'avait pas besoin de prêt vous il
n'avait pas besoin de prêts move elias
ohlala non il ya tout qui tombe elias
pourquoi tu nous fais ça c'est la
catastrophe à d'alesani elias y perd
tous ses pions au nom elias a non qu'est
ce qui nous a fait la liane roy qui
montrent ian pion qui pousse
[ __ ] mais quatre des cinq abandonne
ah non je suis deg et c'est la dernière
partie des amis on va la perdre
aïe aïe d'héroïne damien une bonne non
il va se faire mater dias